(audience cheering)
- I will tell you,
I have interviewed so many people.
I'm so lucky, this job has been,
I've been so fortunate to
get to meet a lot of people
that I love and inspire me.
I have been asking my producer
when this show is going to happen,
for I don't know how long,
and I loved the film.
It was so good, it was so moving.
I laughed, I cried, I was inspired.
It was thought provoking.
There were so many things
happening with the film.
And it's great to have you here.
Thank you for taking the time.
- Thank you for having us.
(audience clapping)
- You're so busy winning awards.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
- But it's great to see you again Marlee.
Thank you for coming back.
- So I was counting the days
when I was gonna come
back to see you again.
Thank you for having us here,
and I love your show so much.
I love you, I Love you, I love you.
And speaking about, I love you,
we are giving you a gift here.
- [Kelly] Oh? What?
- Here, this is for you.
- What?
- This is a very special gift,
that was made for you,
I'm giving to you, by my best friend,
her name is Alexis Kashar.
- [Kelly] My makeup
artist is gonna hate me.
(Kelly laughing)
That's so sweet!
- And it's a sign for I
love you, it's a pendant.
- That's so sweet.
(audience clapping)
So why I'm crying-
- It's a line of jewelry
called RoseBYANDER,
so that's the name of the
jewelry and it's just to,
I love you
- I love it.
One of a kind special jewelry.
- It's amazing 'cause
it's coming from you.
It's also a very special
meaning, side note for me
and my daughter that I won't say on-air
because I'll cry.
But anyway, there's something special
with this sign with me and my kid as well.
So this is very beautiful.
Thank you so much!
(audience clapping)
Had any of y'all met before this movie?
- Yeah, we did, we knew each other.
We all knew each other.
The three of us knew each other
but actually working as
intensely as we did on this film,
no, we didn't actually.
So I'm so honored to have
worked with the two of them.
They're so talented deaf actors,
and it was really more
special to have Amelia
on board with us as well.
This is the perfect cast.
You'll never see a more perfect cast.
(audience cheering)
- I could not agree more.
It was, and I've never seen it on film.
That's why I think this
is so important in film.
I've never seen a full cast like this.
I never really had to watch
or pay attention in a different way.
It was such a beautiful
and needed experience that I
did not know that I needed.
And I did not know that
American Sign Language
it's so passionate.
It's a passionate language.
I mean, it's a full body you're
not just using your voice.
It's a full body experience
of how deeply hurt you are,
- Right.
- Or how deeply in love you are,
or, you know, frustrated you are.
It was just such an
amazing thing to watch.
- Exactly, it's because it's two things.
We are able to express ourselves,
our language within deaf culture,
but we're also damn good actors.
So that's all you can say,
I mean, when you do it then you sell.
- [Kelly] Yeah! Yeah!
(audience cheering)
But, this movie is one that most people
the majority of people
probably aren't accustomed to.
I mean, there are all
other kinds of movies,
and those are all wonderful films
but this is unique and
it's special in itself,
and the fact that there's so
many different levels operating
at the same time in the
film, people will connect
to whatever level that
they're watching in the film
whether it's fishing, or songs,
or music, or sign language, or schools,
or teenage life, or family
life, it's all in one film.
It's the entire package.
It's a beautiful, wonderful
package for the audience.